Hi, I'm John Green and welcome to Crash Course
Big History where today we are going to get a life.
Or at least the Earth is going to
get a life.
But first, today we have to start with a disclaimer.
The origin of life is in many ways a "blank
spot" in the pages of history. Like, the mystery
surrounding the big bang or dark matter - the
origin of life is still pretty puzzling to
us. Like, thanks to scientific research, we
have a general idea of what needed to happen to
bring about life, but we're pretty fuzzy on the details.
Mr Green, Mr Green! I mean, if we don't know,
then why are we studying it as history? Maybe
we should just like, let scientists figure
all that stuff out and then they'll get back
to us, like, after this class is over?
Well, Me From the Past, I'm sure the thousands
of scientists working on that question appreciate
your patience, but even when we have blank
pages in the annals of history, it's still history!
Like, there's still competing ideas
and theories about the presidency of Franklin
Delano Roosevelt, but the fact that there are
open questions doesn't mean it didn't happen!
Sometimes we don't have a clear narrative
of events, and it's up to us to collect more
evidence and refine those theories. But first,
we have to know about the current evidence
and the current theories. I mean, ultimately,
that's what history is!
[Theme Music]
I'm Hank Green, and this is still Crash Course
Big History. Last time we left off with a
newly-born Earth that was molten hot and pelted
by asteroids. Then millions of years of torrential
rainfall cooled the surface and created the
first oceans.
We know that life emerged in the oceans between
3.5 and 4 billion years ago. We have solid
fossil evidence for life 3.5 billion years
ago and many scientists are pretty confident
that life was around 3.8 billion years ago.
It's pretty clear that life is a different
thing from the rest of the universe, but what
makes up that difference? I'm kind of surprised
that this turns out to be a super puzzling
question that we have yet to come up with
a 100% satisfying answer to. But some of the
major characteristics of most life are: it
adapts to the environment, it has a metabolism
that processes energy to keep itself going
(like humans do with pizza), and it reproduces
- whether it be a cell splitting in two or
two animals... doing their thing in nature.
Even these simple criteria have their problems
though. Some animals like mules are born unable
to have offspring. Some micro-organisms can
shut down their metabolisms for long stretches
of time, but neither are exactly dead or not
life.
Given the incredible variety of species,
definitions for life are, by necessity, very broad.
But one such definition by big historian Fred
Spire, is, and I quote "a regime that contains
a hereditary program for defining and directing
molecular mechanisms that actively extract
matter and energy from the environment, with
the aid of which, matter and energy are converted
into building blocks for its own maintenance,
and if possible, reproduction."
In other words, what makes you different from
a star is that while a star burns down till
it dies and doesn't actively float around the
cosmos looking for more fuel, a living organism
does actively seek out pizza to keep itself going,
preferably long enough to, you know, have some babies.
But how do we know what we know? How do we
know that life is just a different kind of molecular
mechanism, not something more profound? Well,
we can test these claims. And we do! Using science.
Because life looks so radically different
from the inanimate universe, people once thought
that life was made of completely different
stuff. Then, in 1828, a German chemist, Friedrich
Wöhler, used inorganic chemicals to synthesize
an organic chemical. This was a big deal - just
as Newton's theory of gravity showed that
the heavens and Earth followed the same physical
laws, Wöhler's experiment proved that life
and non-life follow the same chemical laws,
which implied that life could emerge from
non-life.
Even this idea wasn't completely new. For
centuries, the Aristotelian idea that life
just spontaneously emerged from non-life was
widely believed. For example, if you put some
rotten meat out in the sun, eventually the
meat would transform itself into maggots.
You can probably work out the weaknesses in
this theory. Seventeenth century scientists
took meat and various other objects thought
to spontaneously generate life, boiled them
to kill off any eggs previously laid by insects,
sealed them in jars and nothing happened.
Oh, Aristotle, first you told us that snot
was our brain coming out of our noses, and
now you made all those nice people waste their
steak dinner!
This, however, did not rule out some form
of life-force in the air. Some invisible force
from the Earth's atmosphere that could enter
an object and literally breathe life into
it. But spores from plants can also travel
in the air, as can microorganisms. So in the
mid-nineteenth century, Louis Pasteur boiled
some organic broth, friendly to life and placed
it in a flask with a swan neck, to trap plant
spores in smaller particles. If a life-force
was in the air, it could enter freely, while
spores and other particles would get trapped
in the U-bend. And what happened? Nothing!
A century and a half later, those flasks are
still devoid of life. The conclusion? The
ancients were wrong. After a dose of claim-testing,
it became clear that life must emerge from
the inanimate world by chemical processes
that are discoverable by science.
But what did early life look like? Well, for
a whopping 2.1 billion of the 3.8 billion
years of the evolutionary epic, history was
made by tiny single-cell organisms called
prokaryotes. That's roughly 55% of the entire
story of life. Now, some of those prokaryotes
evolved about 1.7 billion years ago into slightly
bigger single-celled organisms called eukaryotes,
and then, you know, that kept happening and
then eventually - us!
But for now, let's just talk about prokaryotes.
Prokaryotes lived in the seas and ate chemicals
in their surrounding environment. Now these
microscopic prokaryotes might not sound very
impressive, but they do make up the vast majority
of your family tree. They're also distant
relatives of the modern bacteria that are
everywhere, crawling around the room that
you're in right now, crawling all over you, crawling inside
of your intestines. That's right, somewhere, right now,
there is a bacterium that will give you food poisoning,
in an under-cooked hamburger, and it is your cousin!
But the thing is, even in its earliest stages,
single-cell life was massively complex compared
to the inanimate universe. I mean, I know
these are tiny, little specks, but compared
to everything else that had happened on Earth
until them, they were an immense tangle of
chemical networks and building blocks.
But how did an object as ridiculously complex
as a prokaryote first emerge? Well, first
of all, it's very difficult to think of how
life would form in an oxygen-rich atmosphere
like present-day Earth. Oxygen is kind of
a nasty, highly-reactive chemical. In fact,
if the oxygen levels in this room were substantially
higher and I was to just rub my hands together
really fast, I could burst into flames! And
while that would make for a nice viral YouTube
video, I would rather not be on fire than
get lots of views!
3.8 billion years ago, the free oxygen content
of the atmosphere was at negligible levels,
which had some not-so-pleasant consequences.
For millions upon millions upon millions of
years, life dwelled fairly deeply in the ocean,
eating chemicals and staying where the Earth's
heat kept it warm. Eventually, some prokaryotes
floated near to the top of the ocean and started
using sunlight, water, and the carbon dioxide
that was abundant in the Earth's atmosphere
to sustain their own complexity using this
sweet chemical process they'd come up with
called photosynthesis. The waste product of
this chemical process is oxygen, and these
photosynthesizing prokaryotes pumped a lot
of it into the atmosphere.
By around 2.5 billion years ago the amount
of free oxygen in the atmosphere was up to
about 3%. Oxygen can be nasty, and so scores
and scores of tiny single-celled organisms
couldn't handle it, and died off in a massive
wave, sometimes known as The Oxygen Holocaust.
So many species of single-celled organisms,
each with the potential to evolve into more
complex life were wiped out. Even at this
early stage, our evolutionary ancestors were
squeezed through a bottleneck. And this would
not be the last such disaster that nearly
wiped everything out. Next time you have a
bad day, remember that it is amazing that
you are alive at all, much less a member of
a self-aware species, living at the height
of human technological progress.
Speaking of ancestors, somewhere between 1.6
and 2 billion years ago, the eukaryotes evolved.
And because you, your dog, the chicken you
ate last week, and the mushroom you ate the
week before all descended from them, they
really put the "you" in "eukaryotes."
And eukaryotes contained organelles, like
cellular organs that enhanced their abilities.
About 1.5 billion years ago, eukaryotes invented
sex. Up until that point, single-celled organisms
split in two or cloned, with no need to find
a partner for romance and DNA exchange.
Sexually reproducing eukaryotes possibly obtained
these abilities through cannibalism - just eating
each other, which may have led to some accidental
exchange of DNA. After that, the evolutionary
advantages of sex probably resulted in it
catching on. Having a partner means having
two sets of genes and thus a wider range of genetic
diversity from which evolution can pick and choose.
Sex, is a huge deal. It enhanced evolution
and therefore deserves to be classed as one
of the most revolutionary advances in the
history of life on Earth. And, a huge leap
forward in the rise of complexities since
the very beginning of the Universe.
So where did these complex single-celled organisms
come from in the first place? Well, Charles
Darwin's own hypothesis was that life evolved
in some, quote, "warm, little pond, suitable
for fostering life." Other scientists postulate
that life may have formed from organic chemicals
next to the warmth of underwater volcanoes.
And still others champion the idea of panspermia
which states that life may have evolved elsewhere
in the solar system and then been transported
here by an asteroid, which seeded the Earth.
Like I said, this is a 'blank spot', where
many different historical theories are seeking
evidence to clarify what happened. It is possible,
actually, that this problem could be solved
in our lifetimes, which is pretty exciting.
Anyway, whatever physical forces were at play,
primitive organic chemicals eventually came
together into balls with protective membranes.
They would've reproduced and proliferated
much as life does today, but the earliest
blobs of organic chemicals would have reproduced
clumsily, inaccurately, with many useful adaptations
getting lost. Essentially, these molecular
mechanisms were badly programmed.
In 1950s, James Watson, Francis Crick, Mauris
Wilkins, and Rosalind Franklin discovered
how living cells replicate, using DNA, or
deoxyribonucleic acid. DNA is a double-stranded
molecule that contains a list of orders for
how it wants a living cell to be constructed.
And then, a single strand, RNA, reads those
program orders and sets in motion the production
of the proteins necessary to accomplish them.
All life on Earth has DNA, which is one of
the reasons we know that all living things on Earth,
from farmers to fish, from moles to microbes,
have a common ancestor. It's why you share
98.4% of your DNA with a chimpanzee, and why
you share nearly half of your DNA with the
banana that it likes to eat. Not quite cannibalism,
but we do eat a lot of our distant cousins.
But where do DNA and RNA come from? Another
mystery. How could such complex programming
evolve from simpler organic forms? One leading
contender is the RNA World Hypothesis, which
postulates that there might've been an earlier
version of just RNA, which was capable of
both coding and self-replicating, and out
of which separate and more complex structures
evolved, DNA. DNA and RNA operate in extremely
complex ways themselves, which is what you'd
expect with something with as many connections
and varied building blocks as life.
By the way, we're not expecting you to come
away from this video with a complete understanding
of how DNA works. There is a link in the description
to our Crash Course Biology video on DNA,
though, if you want this mind-boggling concept
to come down a few boggles on the boggles-scale.
Remember this as well: when looking at a historical
narrative, it's always useful to know how
things work. But it is still more useful to
know why they work, because they can influence
the future sequence of events. Like, you don't
have to know exactly how to design, build,
assemble, and fire a fifteenth century longbow
to understand the French and English conflict
in the Hundred Years War; all you need to
know is that longbows made things pretty unpleasant
for a lot of French people. Like, "There's
a piece of wood sticking out of me!"-unpleasant.
DNA replication is an amazing, flabbergasting
process that allows life to copy itself and
sustain its own complexity. It copies a living
organism with stunning precision. But even
this impeccable copying process can occasionally
be... somewhat, peccable. Once every billion
copies or so, there is an error. These errors
result in a slight mutation. These can have
no effect, they can be very good, or they
can be very bad. If useful, it allows an
organism to be more successful and likely
to pass on its genes. If not so useful, things
go poorly, and the gene does not get passed
on. On the scale of millions of years, these
copying errors are the engine of evolution
and the origin of new species. They allow
the tiny layer of fragile organic materials
sitting atop of the hulking geological structures
of the Earth to be shaped and reshaped like
play-doh from prokaryotes to eukaryotes to
trilobites to dinosaurs to Abraham Lincoln.
As Charles Darwin put it at the end of the
Origin of Species, "there is a grandeur in
this view of life, with its several powers,
having been originally breathed into a few
forms or into one, and that whilst this planet
has gone cycling on according to the fixed
law of gravity, from so simple a beginning,
endless forms most beautiful and most wonderful
have been, and are being, evolved."
More on that next time.